[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolf from
tech talk i'm arben kalzicci a content
developer and instructor with the wolf
from you team and today i have here with
me rory folger an instructional designer
and technologist
they work on
basically everything education related i
think it's kind of ill-defined honestly
yeah i agree with that yeah but today
they're going to be telling us about uh
well curriculum design and computational
thinking more generally so take it away
rory
awesome uh hi so i
yeah i work with the education programs
at wolfram so especially
the high school summer camp our middle
school summer camp um our emerging
leaders program
which is a follow-up to our high school
camp
uh
student ambassador program um and a few
other uh smaller smaller things that are
less public facing so the first question
is are you okay
am i okay yeah i'm sorry
it's a lot it's a lot summer was hard
but uh we're recovering now that we're
into september and the summer programs
are very worth it the summer programs
are great and we get a lot out of the
kids and the kids have a great time
it's a lot of fun yeah they're fantastic
definitely a highlight but yeah long
days as we've said yeah
yeah um
yeah so for the
high school summer camp is our kind of
most is our longest serving program um
so i think this year was was our 10th
our 10th year that we've done the summer
camps at some of the high school sum
camp um
and so that's you know obviously for the
kind of high school age kids it's a two
and a half week camp where they
do a kind of a project over the course
of two and a half weeks where they
really like dive deep into a subject
that really interests them um and we
kind of blend that with a lot of
instruction in language and
computational thinking and then a lot of
like
content in a whole variety of spaces so
um
you were a mentor this year at camp and
you gave a computational art yes uh
lecture which was super interesting um
and everybody else gives a whole variety
of stuff you know everything from kind
of cryptography to art to music to yoga
and like how we apply competition to
all of these really
varied subjects um which is really fun
and it's something like 30 to 40
students right yeah i think this year we
have 45 uh right yeah so i think we've
i think we and last year we had 45 as
well so you know we're kind of averaging
out at 45 right now and they all have
their own individual projects so i know
how those are chosen but would you like
to talk a little bit how those are
chosen yeah yeah so the students um
tell us all the things that they are
interested in um and
tell us like
what they're excited to explore what
skills they want to learn what skills
they already have
and then um
as as the camp director um i work with
stephen wolfram to
brainstorm a whole lot of projects that
they could do and kind of try and match
them up a little bit uh with what
they're you know between their interests
and their skills and what we can offer
what our mentors are strong at there are
over 100 projects to choose yes there's
a long list of projects that the kids
can kind of choose between
and then each student meets uh
individually with stephen wolfram to
talk through
um either a project idea that they've
proposed or one that they've kind of
chosen off his list
and then you know we kind of
merge all of those things together into
a project that they do and they're
usually
pretty intense projects they kind of
range from the like upper high school to
lower college level kind of academic
work
um
and each kid has a
mentor that they work with through the
through the week and
sort of kind of collaborative
work that they do with other students um
but yeah mostly the kind of
the goal for the kids of summer camp is
doing this project and the goal for us
um well the goal the goal for me
specifically is like
i want them to come out with all this
computational thinking like ability and
a lot of critical thinking a lot of like
growth mindset stuff i want to try and
develop their
their mindsets and the ways that they
think about learning um because we get a
lot of kids who come in and they're like
apologizing all the time and telling us
that you know oh i can't do it it's hard
and i'm like
i'm so sorry i'm 15 and i'm really bad
at this like college college-level math
right i'm like oh how dare you be
15
how could you do that to me
um
but yeah so i really try and like
encourage this this mindset of
development and learning and growth and
iteration you know you never get
something right first time
and you know this is how computer
scientists and scientists and stuff
actually work it's a good lesson for
them to learn at that age and uh you
know we both know that they are learning
it at that point because
you know the final product in a sense
that the kids make is a computational
essay which is you know a notebook that
has kind of their collected thoughts
their code some explanations some
visualizations you know conclusions that
they found
kind of everything that they've done
throughout it's a representation of that
and you know
a lot of them will do this and they they
get very worried about it
i mean there's some self-selection of
course for people who are interested to
come to a camp like this but yeah they
get very concerned about it but it's
okay yeah they got to learn that soon
exactly early on rather exactly
yeah and then my my favorite part is we
we take
about half of the kids from the summer
camp um afterwards and we bring them
into the wolfram emerging leaders
program which was founded
in 2019 and the kids
voted to shorten that to whelp so
they're all part of the the wealth
program
and
we
uh i put them into groups um into groups
of three or four or five students um and
they work
on a group project um over the course of
an entire semester um instead of like a
single project over the course of two
weeks and so it's a very different
atmosphere you know they have a lot more
time to really develop their like
thoughts and ideas and do more research
um
and
they get to do a lot more collaboration
and work together in a team and is that
the sort of thing where you know it's
kind of after their regular schooling or
during weekends whatever times they can
find that work between the three or four
or five students yeah exactly yeah so um
and they usually they're a pretty
international bunch um so i try and
organize them like by both interest and
by
time zone um you know so we try not to
have you know two in america and one in
korea and then it doesn't doesn't work
nobody can do it that's that's one of
the difficulties of running a virtual
campaign it is well it yeah yeah but um
yeah wealth is really cool you know and
they uh they do a lot more um
they do a big mix of like design
thinking and computational thinking uh
so we take them through
kind of iteration and um
and ideation kind of as a methodology um
so
building their projects from nothing
coming up with hundreds of thousands of
you know
ideas um
i tell them like 95 of what you come up
with is going to be bad and that's great
we love that um and then they always
come up with
these really insanely detailed deep
projects that i was never expecting um
and definitely like better than anything
that i wrote until like junior year of
college like really great subjects yeah
really impressive kids yeah it's
fantastic so you mentioned design and
computational thinking could you
elaborate a little bit on the
differences between these two things
yeah totally so computational thinking
um
you know has all kinds of formal
definitions um
some of which
stephen wolfram has contributed to and
some of which are different to
his his view um for me uh conversational
thinking is
less about like your ability to code um
like critical thinking isn't about your
ability to read um it's you know it's
more than that
um
and so computational thinking for me is
like
the the process of
taking a problem and splitting it into
its parts finding out like really what
the goal
of of your problem solving is spilling
into its parts finding patterns and
solutions and algorithms that help you
to
solve it
trying again failing iterating over and
over again and then eventually you kind
of
wrap everything up together and you come
to
a solution um which then usually
requires testing like
the the the process of problem solving
with conversational thinking for me is
is uh
never over yeah i have this particular
graphic in mind as you make these hand
motions there's like yeah there's like a
helical structure that describes these
steps of computational thinking yeah and
we can include that in the description
yeah yeah
yeah i think it's a it's a
computer-based math website yeah yeah
it's a reasonable way to think about
this yeah i think yes yeah i think i
think the camps in particular do a
really good job of instilling these
ideas in the students and i'm glad that
you know some of them get to have this
experience after the camp to
extend this because you know
if you check out the projects these kids
do in i mean the camp as you said it's
about two and a half weeks but they're
only working on their projects for about
i would say 12 days of that maybe less
than that 10 10. yeah yeah so they do an
unbelievable job of putting out just
incredible projects in that amount of
time but even that said it still is 10
days yeah so having some more time
available
you know that's got to produce some
pretty interesting results
so what other you know what are the
things do you work on that you uh
inject computational thinking into for
lack of a better phrase yeah
uh so this year was our first um
our first middle school summer camp um
so we designed this
one week program um
for kind of 11 to 13 year olds
um and we're really focusing on um girls
and
other non-non-binary uh and queer
individuals
um
to
pull that that group um into stem
um and so it's a really
uh focused week for these
young kids um to
our real goal is computational thinking
then so they don't do a project they
don't do like a lot of external stuff
they don't really talk to
um many wolfram employees uh it's just a
kind of one week introduction to wolfram
language and computational thinking and
so all of our mentors for that all of
the teachers are
alumni from our high school summer camp
um so all these kind of 19 20 year old
really excited kids who've been part of
summer camp and part of welp
and you know coming back to mentor these
these younger kids
and
during that week we
um
we run through
sections of the elementary introduction
to wolverine language um and so we learn
like
how to make lists and what an
association is and all of the like super
basic like syntax stuff
but what we really focus on
is the development of this computational
thinking
structure within these kids heads um so
we want them to
come out of there being able to problem
solve um so we give them you know we
send them off into workshops and we say
you know um
make some
art
with your coding and they look at me and
they're like
what does that mean that's not a task no
you haven't told me what to do what's
the output that you want and i'm like
clearly clearly these kids should have
come to my lecture in the high school
they should have they should they would
have understood yeah we did give them
the notebook
but um yeah and so you know we'll send
them off with like a very kind of
ill-defined task
and tell them to to make something with
code um
and you know the first couple of days
they're super shy they don't know what
they're doing they they look at you like
you're crazy when you ask them to just
do something open-ended because that's
not how a school functions yeah um
and then by the end they're like
really excited and they're messaging me
all these cool like random code snippets
that they've made and they're you know
doing stuff in
3d and they're making
graphs and they went and found a data
set online and now they've made a neural
net and i'm like i didn't teach you to
do that but cool well done yeah middle
school skynet camp yeah horrifying yep
it's uh it's really exciting yeah it's
really nice for them to get the
experience kind of early on there
because
i think a lot of people find even um
even compared to say undergrad you know
once you get deeper into academia or you
know you go into the job market you'll
find that a lot of tasks are actually
not that well defined right and nothing
is defined if you sit there kind of
freaking out and looking at everybody
like what am i gonna do you know like
they do in those first few days yep um
it's not a good look so it's it's nice
to get that out of the way early yeah
totally yeah if the first piece of
open-ended stuff that you do is your phd
dissertation then somebody's failed you
yeah that might make it slightly harder
yes not necessarily the easiest thing to
begin with
yeah and that's uh that's a new program
right it's only yeah it's a brand new
program so we did that this year for the
first time that was that was virtual
yeah
yeah and i i know that some of the some
of the mentors for the middle school
camp came back and their tas you said
there's kind of yeah the mentors for
that were tas for the summer camp but
then some of the mentors from the middle
school camp came back and we're tas
again for the high school camp and i
think everybody i spoke to had worked on
that just had a really nice time yeah
yeah and it's nice because we have this
kind of uh
what what what i'm trying to do in in my
job at wolfram is create a kind of
pipeline for
people to really
get into using wolfram language and to
get into coding and into stem in general
um and now we you know we start at 11
and we get these uh middle school camp
kids um to come to the high school camp
and then the high school camp kids they
come to the emerging leaders program and
then they come and they'd be a ta at the
high school program or they'd be a
mentor at the middle school program and
then they go to our summer school for
college students and for other adults
and so it's like a whole computational
thinking pipeline yep that's a whole
life but but seriously though it's
really nice that uh you know at that
younger age they both get the experience
of learning and then they get to go back
and take what they've learned and use it
to teach other students i mean
i'm i'm biased because i've done a lot
of you know teaching in my life but i
find that i find that teaching is really
a fantastic way to kind of you know
solidify and expand your own
understanding of
whatever material yeah so it's nice that
they get that no it's really fun
so if students are interested in
applying for either of these camps where
should they go
well our
applications open
in kind of late december early january
and they can go to the
website for the um high school summer
camp or the middle school summer camp um
which i believe is on our education
programs page which is a new page which
is exciting
um
and
yeah i really i encourage people to
apply as early as they can um there's a
for the high school camp there's
uh we send you a problem set so you're
asked to kind of learn just a little bit
of wolfram language before you
uh submit your application fully um
which is a exciting opportunity even if
you don't come kids can apply um
in january through the website and uh
it's pretty soon it's pretty soon yeah
we're coming up already yeah uh
september went high real fast yeah um
yeah and
if you want to see projects that uh kids
did last year the year before and all
the way back uh to
i guess 2011 um you can go to the
wolfram community website um which has
all their computational essays uh
they're all tagged with
wsc and i think i think there's a
there's a tumblr page we maintain there
is a tumblr page there's a bunch of like
beautiful thumbnails of all the cool
visualizations from all the kids results
yep yep so that's all on the website as
well you can click on the gallery make
sure we'll make sure to include that so
that viewers can take a look at that
it's very it's very cool yeah it takes a
lot of effort
all right well thanks a lot for all of
that information rory it's nice to see
what you know what we're getting up to
on an education front especially you
know it's one thing
our software is uh distributed in a lot
of universities of course you know
basically every top university has a
site license with us right and that's
you know very good we love that but it
was also great for high schoolers and
middle schoolers to kind of get a chance
to get in on this stuff earlier instead
of just you know coming to the software
and like ah i need to
do an integral that i don't know how to
do you know it's there's a lot more
there than that so it's nice to get them
introduced earlier on
right well thanks a lot rory thanks i
appreciate it see you next camp
that was rory folger and they told us
about the many educational opportunities
that we are offering here at wolf firm
in particular the summer programs and
the post summer programs if i can call
them that
so remember the applications open up in
december january if you're interested or
maybe your children are interested in
signing up for the summer camps
applications open pretty soon so keep an
eye out for those we hope to see you for
future tech talks we have plenty coming
up and we would love if you would listen
to them there's plenty of information
there that i think you would find very
interesting so hope to see you in the
next one bye
[Music]
you